Beyond these programs there's a need
to change incentives in at least
three ways.
The first is reimbursement for
the expense of the electronic
health record system.
The second is some ongoing financial
incentive to use the system properly.
The Medicare and Medicaid incentive
programs were designed to do the first.
The Medicare payment program may do
the second through penalties for
providers in hospitals who
don't achieve meaningful use.
It's increasingly possible that private
health insurance companies may start
funneling patients to providers who
have achieved meaningful use and
the prospect of that
is another incentive.
The third needed incentive is changing
reimbursement to some form of pay for
performance to further
reward providers for
improving care efficiency and quality.